hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play
feck hat Carrodus okay um as you can see
I managed to get two of the coals out I
wasn't sure if I definite we start the
game or what but I'm out of oil and
there's his weird noise Ajay Don ha ha
ha ha so I I managed to get these out by
wiggling very vigorously like I just
grabbed it and twisted it back and forth
over and over again till it popped out
ah man [ __ ] good after it did but yeah
anyway so that's what I did and that's
why I got but my vision is starting to
go oh that worked and now I'm all sorts
of wobble ofc and Evo she did haha ok so
they added in that weird sound effect
when your sanity starts to go that's
pretty bad I mean the atmosphere is
great I love it is terrifying oh man I
was just watering around the dark for a
bit I wasn't even recording it this is
kind of tried to avoid that guy that
monster was everywhere as I was just
trying to okay that's two or should be
so I just need to get the other three
the other three are still in the pipe
but I didn't get a chance to wiggle them
out because mister guy here or mr. face
is manga minks calls him decided to pay
me a visit and I did not appreciated
okay so I just got to get around to the
other pipe and I should be good sorry
about his so dark I'm out of oil
ah come on Jesus Christ go away man he's
everywhere
I can't seem to get around him
come on come on come on okay I'm not
saying that this is easy but this is the
best I just wiggle it vigorously until
it oh it popped out yeah it is okay
that's one rah
I must say that I probably found the
most creative way to break the game oh
here we go that was an easy one and
topped out quick and then one more come
on round one
I gotta oh Jesus balls [ __ ] off
hey man awesome why didn't I get any
warning what happened to my early
detection system does it come from
need to get that last one I gotta get it
ah yeah I got a guy a wet summer [ __ ]
what summer I don't know where I went
I'll find it later it's orange and
glowing can't be that hard
oh I hope it didn't go into a wall or
something
I would not put it past that okay just
set these years
Oh Eva why are you even here ah it is
not going well these are extra steps
that I shouldn't have to take cuz duh I
blame the game maker for this not
obviously not my fault I'm Way too smart
to be tricked into thinking that those
pipes were where I was supposed to put
him
given that they jut out from the walls
oh so perfectly job I'm not dumb I'm not
dumb is really really really dark Oh dah
I have torches why haven't I been
lighting anything okay maybe he's gone
away oh I haven't been lighting anything
ah ha ha ha why haven't I been doing
that
I'm a [ __ ] okay I gotta find where did
that other one go it vanished like
seriously it went away I shook it too
vigorously and it probably busted
through a wall or something I gotta be
here
where'd it go you can't agon this far
it had to be oh man maybe it got oh boy
I hope I didn't lose that cannon like
I'm just thinking I'm worried that it
might have gone into a room like through
a wall because if I can shake it out of
the thing then is every possible ha-ah
you're gonna be gone
you killed my hero you need to go I hop
- you had your fun let me just grab this
other one got here
I'll look for it while I'm running
probably one was that no there's a pile
of bones I'm looking for something
orange and glowing it cannot be this
hard to find where did it go if I lost
it in oh if it fell out of the level I
will be so upset ah damn it
everything was going so smoothly I got
four or five and the last one decides to
dick me over your vug off god damn I
mean I don't know how I find the ways to
break these games so much it's
ridiculous like I shouldn't be able to
do this as much as I do like anyone
who's watched a lot of my amnesia I
break the game's a lot it's uncanny
it's uncanny how do I do it I don't know
okay I got to assume that that last coal
is in there because the alternative is
surreal Oh to save and I'll do that Oh
do that
I've dealt with that monster enough oh
I'm pretty sure like uh well I mean
there's still obviously gonna be a dick
punching party for this guy
damnit need that last one
Roger son where did it go
burn Inuk where I wish I had oil oh man
is the worst couldn't have gone in one
of these I checked this room actually
that's right
oh it couldn't have gone in a room could
it could it oh shut up guy
you're such an a-hole I never I don't
remember this guy paying this much of a
dick worrying at I didn't go ah come on
[ __ ] up okay I've already checked hair
are you banging on a door I'm not in
there she's so stupid
[ __ ] your Chuck stupid ah oh come on
[ __ ] dammit and I think I think I think
that coal is gone how do I do this
ah alright I'll be back
alright I'm back and backtrack a bit and
it's been a while since I played this
game without doing anything wait a
minute oh man I'm a little bit farther
back than I wanted to be but at least
I've got some oil recall going down here
I kind of want to see what's the goings
on in the basement
oh okay this is this is just to the oh
this is just to the thingy sewer thingy
oh I thought that was something else
here I guess not
some sort why would they need an
observation for the sewer I have no idea
but anyway now I'm back the coals are
still in their room so I need to go read
the letter you unlock those doors bolt
in Dodge mr. face and then get the stuff
that I need da-da-da-dah blah blah blah
blah blah I've got a mission to
accomplish ha
doors blowing up and in the wind your
honor Rama I actually do have good bit
of oil because I sprinted through the
last part without using my Lantern which
was not very conducive to happy fun
times but I take what I could get I'd
rather have oh the torture sounds how I
have myth you
so I just oh hello oh that's right
there's one in here
oh no he Dulce da yah si si por favor
ah come on what could go no why are
there so easy to break
oh man did you see what I just did I
somehow managed to push this through the
wall through the frickin wall how did I
do
Oh powder you ha I am a gamebreaking
master all the game developers if
they're even watching this are probably
like how do you do that oh that
shouldn't be possible I'm just imagining
their accents I'd like to think of them
as a portion splendiferous but anyway
okay that's one define more they're big
and glowing in orange
yeah we all got problems
oh don't push it through any doors again
if I do I'm going to be so upset leave
that there for safekeeping I mean it was
perfectly understandable that it might
maybe have needed to go into those pipes
I thought it was perfectly reasonable
and anyone who doesn't think so I will
depart some into dick my signature move
I was a superhero on my trading card
super dick
does 20 damage okay oh okay again oh
shut up shop hey oh shut up a [ __ ]
do you imagine me to pro so one in here
I think I want I've gotten three so far
three or I don't remember how many I've
got I think this is a fourth maybe yeah
this is the fourth right ah be like that
screaming in your face I guess you just
cut him
shut up you're right behind me aren't
you Jesus go I your persistent you're
awfully persistent hi my famiiy later i
got my load mom mother god damn that guy
is all over me
hi then again good price uh oh my god
markiplier give me your okra oh my god
me biggest fan and I was like uh yeah I
know baby
oh you ugly but I know wait where's the
last fun I don't even see another cell
door that's open been in there I'm not
in there are you blocking the last one
you're just randomly Oh what about this
one maybe no I've already been in here
or have I I don't know yeah that where
is it this one
come on come on come on winner winner
chicken dinner
got it all right Josh ah [ __ ] you
blocking my entrance exit and protection
good thing there's to this guy I swear
something about the AI of this grunt in
particular is redonkulous go away go
away if somehow he circled around it is
starting to come what is he doing
I'm sure what a weirdo okay do not
somehow if I managed to push these
through a wall again I'm gonna be so
best yeah Oh throw like a [ __ ] girl but
at least I touch hot coals with my bare
hands it would be a bad idea to throw
them into that pool of water wouldn't it
there's cool off my cold real quick okay
all right we almost got this this puzzle
has taken me way too long to finish I
mean obviously any normal person playing
this game would be like and okay five
coals got to get an end of the thing
okay and then they do it in five minutes
yeah but me I gotta go through all
convoy and waste my oil at the same time
by the by always remember to waste your
oil whenever possible if you're in a
brightly lit area please go ahead turn
on your lantern and immediately start
doing what you need to do get in there I
hope I'm doing this right because if
something goes wrong again I will be so
mad I will be so mad okay just die brah
shop lady like I say we all have
problems what is that doing what ah it's
just some coal calm down calm down
please
Oh Oh what hey why are you blocking me
off well this was obviously an exercise
in futility
da da da da da da God what whoa baby
face no all the doors seemed to be
breaking on their way
I bet they're all locked um boom boom
boom boom bum bum bum bum boo hello ah
ah blue red blue red blue red red red
rod rod rod rod no I get through ah piss
what oh okay I thought I had to choose
okay never mind then
this is weird you do not like that
babyface
I don't have a lantern oh hello wait a
minute there's nothing here
Oh wondered what God break the game
again oh wait what about the only door
that's not broken how about that one
yes oh ha ha ha
oh they tickle ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ok
all these doors are gonna be locked
about my double check just to be sure I
like the little sparkles never notice I
didn't know I am knees you could do
particle effects wave is getting dark ah
that was the end part 1 if wha no no no
that's impossible
it's impossible oh that's it no no oh
come on what's going so good no
you
hmm man that kind of upsets me that I
did I had no idea the ending was coming
glad I didn't cut the part early and I'm
glad that last puzzle took me a while oh
it's so sad I thought there was gonna be
a longer one ah still incredible though
it's still very good so thank you guys
for making bit thank you guys for
watching it thank you good
well actually this wasn't a suggestion I
found it myself
so thank me for me and me I often this
but anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the in faces I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
Oh
but
[Music]